I feel like for podcasts today thinking it's the other person spot. I don't know anybody. I know
psychedelic stigma is gonna go away that's gonna help a fuck flow to people who have not been able to find their alternative in
Advil or in therapy. Wait a minute women
Are you telling me that you feel FOMO when everybody goes out on sucking Thirsty Thursday? And who's the fucking mojito?
Maybe you don't belong here. You still live at home with your parents?
You didn't even go to college you would be so pretty if you just lost 10 pounds. Are you sure that's gonna work?
Beauty epic succeed. You weren't gonna be successful anyway
Just like blocking out the noise in the chaos of Times Square
You need to block out the noise of the judgement your mother your father the cynicism block it out. You can't hear it
Do you understand? You can't fucking hear it?
You do not love losing you lost
Hey guys
Monday
In the Long Island City meeting of meeting Long Island City
Office about to do this meeting with a big executive from big fortune 500 food company just fuckin grindin excited. Kick it off here
We go. What is this nine?
eight
Oh, that's so obvious to me like the whole Aubrey and Ferriss and all that circles what I can tell is that this
psychedelics are only
repressed
Pigma? No, I mean I don't even own a
Cigarette like I'm super weird. But yeah, I drink wine. Um, but I've been drunk like five times
I'm completely sober and I love that but I still love I think yeah
Me too, cuz I don't have feelings and opinions when it comes to business would you do them?
I probably wouldn't because my mom Nancy Reagan me out too much
It's a framework for me
But I'll say this I'll never say never like I'm willing to do whatever the fuck I need to do at any point
It's just not in my framework on the flip side
On I'm also way too
grateful and thankful of my mental happiness
And I would be lying if I didn't tell you that I'd be scared to alter something or you know
A lot of people do it because it finds a dimension that works for them. I'm like my current state is working for me
I don't want to open up something be like. Oh, fuck it like yeah, like like don't fix it yet
But if I wasn't mentally happy I'm open for everything. Everything's in play. Have you heard of MDMA therapy?
No, I think it's a it's awesome Tucker Tucker max has told he's one of our investors. Yep
He's he took because I go to therapy and I used to take antidepressants. He was like dude do this
I've been on this medication for years and I did this thing
I feel way better anything that helps people get off medication is something intuitively in my gut not I'm not a doctor
I don't know like I'm sure there's plenty of medicines that matter
But I'm always pumped knowing enough about the business of Pharma in America
I'm always pumped if people can find a different way but back to psychedelics and like and
Sexual experimentation like what you're seeing right now?
a mature
Practical version of what you saw in the 60s? I think it's a game of stigma. What's an example?
Well, I think you know when I think about my friends in Silicon Valley who talked about you know
Psychedelics and things that nature inevitably in that same dinner it gets into alternative sexual
Relationships and like an open like open marriage is in a more progressive way than open marriages or like I wouldn't know
I don't think I could never do that
it's not for me either like what but I don't like imposing my like what I think makes me successful in these talks is I
Never impose my will or opinion on what will happen all my friends that are like fuck
How do I got tick-tock wrong? It's like and whether tick tock disappears tomorrow or not
There's incredible money being made in the tick-tock infrastructure
And that's what we're talking about business in this narrow way, and I'm they're like, why are you always right?
I'm like cuz I don't impose my opinion
You're cuz I'm talking to these inner circle friends. I'm like you said it was stupid for you
You said that because you're insecure you have 800 thousand followers on Instagram, and you don't want to start over
you're doing what Tila Tequila and Dane Cook did with MySpace you're doing what all my homies and twitter did about Instagram you now are
Doing that to Instagram. You're so set in your thing. And you've got clout. You don't want the world to reset
I only want the world to reset because I don't actually value my clout. I value learnings and impact
It's a huge deal. So help psychedelics real quick to finish this off and then jump in with you for your helps
Psychedelics stigma is gonna go away which is then gonna make people feel comfortable to do it
And I have a very deep intuitive feeling that is the medicine or whatever the fuck you want to call it
That's gonna help a fuckload of people who have not been able to find their alternative in
Advil or in therapy or in much harder core medicine and that excites the shit out of me
I want way more happiness in the world the cash came mine tripping on a pet flame, even if they were dogs any tears
It's the rap game a high school politics boss could be on more because they got a little company before I show up
That's what the deposit is. You only want me now. That's what I believe. I'm building the reverse of the modern private equity bonus
that's what I think Boehner is I think Vayner is
actually a
hyper-growth
Private equity firm in disguise as an agency
My original plan was to convert the whole thing into it
The economy never collapsed and I was fully leveraged into Facebook and other things I believed in long term. So
What's ended up happening now is when that day comes when?
The market collapses and I can buy things for normal prices that were over leveraged
I'll go on to become the CEO of Puma when I buy it or
SodaStream or Opie or or Pete's coffee chain?
And then now the company will last with management and be the sister company
But I'll take the 40 to 50 top talents and bring them to a modern private equity firm. I
Don't think anybody can take any business and create hyper growth the way that I can at scale once this is completed
So what we're doing right now d-roc has a list of
Every platform that we need content. Yeah for
That Gary needs to film so we blocked out
15 minutes. Yeah, Gary's time. I'm we're gonna try to bang it all out. See what he's into see what isn't hot into
What we'd like to say is ideas
You'll probably never get less feedback. Okay. What I know is what I would say no - all right
But like this feel is a super spot on okay
So we want people to smile
When they look at it when something shitty happens. Yeah, that's that's that's that's you know
Yeah, and that's got a little juice to it. Like I'm a little bit like I'm happy with like these are good
Well, I'm sure I'm like kind of trying to define something that's not so commonplace that has its own unique aesthetic to it
Here's the good news, you know, I'm gonna bring so much awareness to it
McDonald's, yeah is actually an Irish pub
It's just they made you realize that it was a fast-food burger and fries joint was it no but its name should be
I'm good. You see where I'm going? Yeah, I'm gonna make America give a fuck about this
I know what I'm doing because because they
And here's a good news. This is where I'm great as a client. Mmm. You know what you're doing. Yeah
Yeah
Just
Like like I know what I'm good at but I'm all vegan
But if we're smart honest, but if we're spending down, but if we're spending your money McDonald's, okay, McDonald's name is an Irish pub
That's not how America does it though, right? Yeah. What the fuck is McDonald's?
McDonald's, you actually like
Its name if we were sitting here today and said we're starting a fast-food joint and I said and you said McDonald's
Any logical person would be like, why are you naming it?
That's right as an Irish thing like to me. I'll make them care. I know you do what you do better than me
I don't need that subjectiveness. I just need the general
Frege's this is Katie
What you're about to see is Daymond John on the garyvee audio experience and it's a smaller part of a longer conversation
with a young entrepreneur
so
People don't know how to save anymore
You know what's happened, you know, what's happening right now
this is where you're getting caught I think tell me if I'm wrong the fact that you're not paying rent and
Saving is allowing you to spend money on a couple things that you wouldn't have and that's where the cycles play
I believe I believe you then then I would say for happiness instead of this happening in the Leben years
Let it happen in 14 years by moving an hour and a half
Again, one more thing though and this is also kind of like with my job and stuff like that
You know, I feel like it's just a lot of people who like don't care about saving and just you know
I you know every every other day going out for drinks is fun. Their life has nothing who gives a fuck right? That's good
I like when everybody else is doing dumb shit. That means I'm about to win
What do you feel wait a minute women
Are you telling me that you feel FOMO when everybody goes out on fucking thirsty first day in drinks a fuckin mojito?
Bro, let me tell you let me tell you something really good don't judge anyone
Okay, you see where I'm going I'm watching a lot of judgment come now, I'm starting to spend some time with you
Like if we were having a for our dinners homies, I blade broke stop judging people
You see window broke
And I got love for you to like honestly
Be empathetic like be grateful that you're not in a model like I what when I talk I hate, you know
I've been trying to tell people I don't have advice I have I'm like every other human we're animals that like to share
Hypotheses opinions are hot takes but like like don't judge them
yeah, and
Don't don't envy them. I hate what people like damn. Yeah, because there's dad's paying for a shit
he gets to go to the club and
Deep down he fucking thinks he's a loser because his dad's paying for everything next next like like oh damn
They're just buying those drinks or those clothes to fit in
Don't judge them feel bad for them that their whole life is about other people's fuckin acceptance
So they have to fucking ruin their own lives just so everybody thinks they're cool. I
Think you're spending a lot of time on judgment. Don't even think about it. I knew nothing. I know nothing
Oh, but anybody was doing in my 20s
I didn't know if they were winning losing
Going out not going out unless they walked into the fucking liquor store which some of them did I literally had no fucking idea
Get quiet and focus on your own shit
We need to as an organization fully understand and it would be huge miss with leaving
An owner and not making this religion and we can have a separate meeting on this
I still think it probably makes sense for everybody in Tom's and media to come and spend a full day with my team
Any I have zero?
One man's point of view. I trust you guys, but this is powerful to me
zero interest in
posting anything organic
Meaning I'll take it
But we must assume that nothing that we post organic is a driver of what we want to happen
So if we create this if we're spending the money and time and effort to capture the content
to think our mother days content is gonna be something in
Twitter is a humongous mess
We need to have a deep conversation of like how we're gonna spend that eighty four dollars on Facebook
Against forty to sixty year old women in Minnesota with that mothers that we have to be that organization
it was just
Please yes
Yes, I want to run $5 ad Spencer on 80 pieces of content a day
I'm happy we're in a really good spot because we have the ability to absolutely have
20 pieces of content, you know organic on Twitter that is so on par with the culture that we're reinforcing
but I think we have to have a strategy around how we're broadening or
Amplifying towards objectives and I think he'd be stunned back to the smile. I had of like 25 dollars in ad spend
It's pretty powerful. I'll give an example. I know that we can run
$250 on Instagram story ads in Minnesota
with a
Instagram overlay sticker of a pole or a question
That will probably give us more insights than every single thing. We've done so far in social
So I think what this leads me to the last meeting we had and now the one we're having now
I think we need to think about
The team coming to New York and spending a full day with my team
So that we can do this patate and then you guys can filter and say we like this
Hey, we don't love this as much. Let's have that combo
So that's where I'm going with that
I just want to make sure that every dollar we spend in media to make something happen
Goes through a veiner test me or my scale team because no one like that is my legacy
Like my legacy is Wine Library really had no money
Like we'd be building my fame like it's it's still money in comparison to impact. I want to make sure that we're scrappy org
I really I want to be great at and I think we have the permission to be great at it
And I think I'm uniquely
You know without hyperbole great at it for like so I want at least transfer that in the best way we can like tick tock
It's we're in the Alpha program beta program. It's one cent views
Like we like let's be the team that has like that, you know, we're gonna have like we're gonna talk about it
But there's gonna be 14 objectives and bucks. Right? So like then synthesizing and saying you know what?
disproportion winning on tick tock is
Perception is reality
And the new thing which is gonna help us get Target for Best Buy
Because when they see that we have five hundred thousand followers on tick tock that's gonna be the new cloud and then Laveau
Helps us get 100k which then helps us spend eight thousand a month. See where I'm going
The blueprint
He said he said that it was talking, Texas, El Paso
It was when you're like the greatest advice I could ever get someone it's do what I believe
That shit
It's it's true because I'm scared to be wrong
You know people see so much for me. I'm always talking, but I don't talk about a lot of stuff
I'm narrow and deep
I'm definitely consistent cuz I'm because I'm narrow and all I'm trying to do is try shit like
The reason I can be right about snap or tick-tock when they pop
it's because I'm already doing and I've seen that something happens there whether they last for 20 years from one year is
Irrelevant, it's do. You know what the fuck is happening right now? Everyone's like Gary
Let's see if tick tock is real. I'm like notes. It's already real what you're asking is
Like Seinfeld was real that was seven seasons
SNL is real for 30 seasons. I would argue Empire was real for two-and-a-half seasons like no
No, there is no let's see if tick tock was real
Tick tocks real it happened. You're saying will it be like vine and go away after three years?
Or will it be like Facebook and have a 20-year run? It's irrelevant because tons of people extracted enormous value
Success happiness and other things from vine in its two years like Charlie D'Amelio
Tik toks real for her forever and whilst other buddy house is waiting to see if it's around for four years before they jump in
That shit
Hey, I'm Andrea, I'm the chief marketing officer
And we just got back from this pretty cool trip to Minneapolis, and we did a bunch of different things
We hung out with some clients, but my favorite thing was we convened a whole bunch of friends and family
For a breakfast people in the Midwest they loved getting together for food. I'm from the Midwest so I can say that from Wisconsin
But yeah
A lot of what we're doing now is we're trying to really capitalize
on the time that Gary has as he's traveling around the country or the world and make the most of it and
so in addition to
Having just kind of one-off meetings
We try to go out and look for people that are you know part of his fan base or different potential
You know business partners that we want to have conversations with and we invite them to come together
and to meet one another and so
What we do is we try to keep them kind of small and create an opportunity for everybody to exchange ideas
And maybe even feel a little bit vulnerable and admitting the kinds of challenges that they're facing
Could be you know in their in their roles, it could be something that's more personal
And the the great thing is that Gary really sets the tone for that in a way that I personally have never seen before
in my career
So he kicks things off by
Welcoming everybody and asking them to join in one conversation. So we might have
12 people or even up to 20 people around a table and we ask that everybody just engages in this one single conversation
So don't break off and have a discussion with your mate neighbor
But rather we tee it up with
You know something that can be highly engaging maybe a little provocative and then people chime on in and it's it's almost a sport
Surprise surprise Gary's always turning everything into a support into a sport
But people we get a lot of great reactions and we get to know people
Really quickly that way and I think people meet one another in a way. That's a bit more memorable
And they meet more people
Rather than just the ones that you're sitting next to at any kind of a marketing or networking event
And so we're trying to do these things across the country and around the world
So hoping to see some of you guys out there and some of our upcoming events
I also think it's gonna be it's the inner
This is the Internet meaning like I would pay $2.99 a month for the Jets for just jets TV
Like the wrong tail of this is quite long, you know like it
I think I think Google is really working on the most interesting part to this which is
The balloons in outer space to give everyone free Internet is the biggest thing that's looming that can change here
If that happens if we up all have internet for free for real and our gateway
Toby is Google's all of a sudden cable televisions and deep shit. Cuz right now they're forcing us
To buy cable because it is it cost more money to buy just Internet that internet and cable
From most internet providers now because we're diggin the outcome of cable because they don't want to give up that game
You you add that variable. I think the number will obviously it's gonna be wealth and interest
It's a combination of how much can you afford and how many things are you actually into?
Correct and then to everyone's point. I'm sure we would all agree spent four hours on this
There'll be a group of four to five that are like the catch-all right is it is your core?
netflix
and this and then all of us would probably round out with the constellations of like three little
$4.99 a month because you're like sewing and like somebody can listen. I'm really excited about this like back to transparency
I genuinely think it's unlikely that I do not launch a veiner ODT in the next 20 years
And I'll just meet my little universe and I'll wherever I am at that point between my content and the things I buy the IP
rights for or develop
I'll have my 1 million subscribers at 8 bucks a month and of you that's a nice business like I like that's fun
That's fun to have a 100 million dollar top-line revenue
You know makes it like I think you're gonna see a lot more of that than people think I think what you're seeing with
Celebrities and humans that are building vtc brands that are actually viable a lot of them are underwater because there's too much VC money
But like actual viable, I think you're gonna see that with content. I really do
I I mean there's a I think all right now I'm so hot on sports cards and Colet like actually flipping if you think about
storage wars and flipper like
clearly there's a flipping OTT like a
that thing OTT for 4 bucks a month that you could have a lot of people and I would be one of those people you
Know WWE there's a lot like you're gonna see a lot of people a lot of people gonna get listen
There's an entrepreneur she or he is sitting right now thinking like wait
I'm gonna get the NBA local rice and the first team is on that's available stimbler
I'm gonna convince them and I'm not so sure they're gonna raise a ton of money there
There's so much money at them that it's gonna make it worth them to take the risk of the Minnesota OTP
It's just all gonna happen. It's cable all over again. It's TV what TV did to radio all over again. It literally never stops repeating
Well, that's what happened with that flexi bowl
When people don't realize in what I'm actually doing is I'm actually building what I think is the next version of private equity
Which is vaynermedia's infrastructure is built to buy businesses, but hyper grow them
Whereas what you're walking into those are financial engineers, right? Those are finance people. Yeah, I'm business growth
so when you buy
Puma
Because you're wealthy enough in nine years and the economy collapses and they were so over leveraged
You can buy it for 400 million instead of 8 billion
That's really my goal. That's my path to the Jets bill this in this chapter
wait for the world to melt by JanSport or puma or
Pete's coffee chain, or
PC Richards some sort of brand become the CEO of that
Buy something that today is 5 billion for 800 million and then flip it for 11 billion because I'm great at that
Right. All right, and then b61 and by the jetson start winning symbols
I love that you will it into existence?
I below I really think it's gonna happen and what's fun is like, you know by that point
we'll know each other for 33 years and like just the stories right you like this fucking like it'll be like he really fucking but
husbands for 30 years
I've vlog we're here in Indy. It's Thursday. It's been a productive week
I'm in a very Midwest kind of all week
Minnesota a couple days ago got into Indy yesterday did a bunch of meetings for Vayner sports
Combine tonight's a big night five of our kids are performing
Primetime for the combine now footballs become a twelvemonth
Sport where people want to watch kids prep for the giraffe on primetime TV
We're going into a very big banner sports meeting now where we're laying out our strategy
post-mortem of this craft class
strategy for the upcoming draft
We got some free agents. We're fucking busy. AJ super busy
Obviously got my hands it a lot of cookie jars. I
Like cookie jars you want to want a visual here?
Avatar, can you draw a really great cookie jar? Thanks bro right here. And so I'm just kind of living it
And I just realized I got a post on Instagram right now
so
I'm gonna do that
Yep, because in 30 minutes behind on the ground
Good question the Iraq there's some time slots. I enjoy
8:30 11:30
3:30 and 7:30 have been my consistent time slot suite or at least testing and obviously it's noon so I missed it
but um, you know
There's some pockets that the data on Instagram shows that are better times for me to post to my community based on
Interaction, how are you?
Hey, this is matsan male head of client services at Vayner sports. I've been working with Gary and AJ for about
Eight to nine years now
I've served in quite a few different roles including Gary's admin for about two and a half years now
with banner sports been here for about
Two or three years and just kind of helping the clients and agents whatever whatever they need
I'm here to support the whole team
And while we were down in Indy we were basically doing that is one our major role
There was to support our clients. We had seven of our clients in Indianapolis all perform really. Well, we're happy about that
But that was our main thing was that we were there to support them and on top of that
kind of the whole football NFL world surrounds around
Indianapolis for the combine so our agents are meeting with teams. Our marketing team is meeting with brands
I'm meeting with anybody who could possibly help me with any of our clients if there's anything that they're looking for, we're gonna get done
So it's kind of it's a who's who down in Indianapolis, and we're trying to meet with everybody and just kind of grow those relations
What's up? Thank you, my man
Thank you so much
Yeah, I'm about to someone a little bit. It's your name. It's Chris. I really appreciate that. What do you do bro?
Good for you
That's what's up some email to Gary a banner media connected with my brother. Maybe we do some business together with Vayner sports
Yeah, it's Gary at vaynermedia
Yeah, we're Vayner sports. They both work
Nice to meet you. Thanks for saying what's up. Just like fucking nice people. Say hello
You say hello good intent look for opportunities. If you don't ask you don't get you don't come in too hot
If you're the person on the receiving end you don't be a fucking dick and you think you're somebody
Nobody of you fucking got a hundred thousand followers over blue fucking cheque and decided you are somebody the fuck. Are you be nice?
It was nice in his own way
It's my guy right here I
Wish the blog was around back then he would know exactly how tight I am with this guy. Oh
Shit, you're right. Do a little fucking recall right there. Boom. Can somebody get me to make little or get me DeMaio?
Not tell the vaynernation
how I
Had to come through for this
Super tight
super tight T rock take this photo we're gonna get this man some serious followers for his
Combo right now grab my phone or use your phone
That's awesome. Nice to meet you, sir
Looks good. Thank you trying
Would be like
It's pretty good. Actually. Yeah, I get by six or seven. It's just that I fucking destroy the other 18 that I'm awake. Yeah, I
Also destroy sleeping. I fucking never what you could break it to my house and punch me in the face
And I don't wake up, but I tell you man better gratitude that I owe you
it's gonna be hard I
Have two sons they're Millennials. They're coming along and the bright millennial dad. I'm cool with it. I love it
I love it on material. Is that love? They just trying to live their best. I love it
but damn it's slow to turn them around and bring them around right I
Have so much content. I have a catalog I have all of this
If I leave this world today
I know I will have greater. Peace
My sons have all of that
Your dad tell them how to get their hundred percent and that's why thank you so much
Glad you see that
I know what the game is. Thank you. Thank you so much
Thank you so much. I'm so glad we met
What that gentleman?
Understands, is that for all the shit we're talking about his
You know apex moment was understanding that when you document and you share
The people who you most care about your family
Get the blueprints they get your thoughts. They get your legacy, you know, so many people
Have lived lives where they wanted to instill wisdom and their truths
And who they were to their family and didn't have the luxury of modern technology in the internet, you know
My great great great grandkids are watching this right now. It happens to me
220 years from now but it's real and so that young man who look like a fucking linebacker
understood that and that's why he's happy and that is what the context of this was which is if you get nothing in
The short-term accomplishments you're looking for from the content you put out on the Internet
You are leaving your legacy for a blueprint at a relationship with you
forevers maybe
Yeah, I think people are insecure and I think when you hide metrics it helps people because they're all pandering clear metrics
And I've not only been a proponent at Highland likes. I actually recently started talking about hiding followers and
and people with like a lot of my friends like whoa, that's gonna hurt you or like
Hurt me. I don't derive my clout or influence or success and definitely not my happiness from how many fucking followers I have
So and and more importantly I know it's hurting others. And so I'm willing to sacrifice
For the greater good of the world
It's laughable that
one would derive their
self-esteem from these metrics and I think the platforms are noticing that and I'm I would argue you may see a day and age when
The most popular platform at the time actually, it's not showing us how many followers one has
Oh, you would know if we eliminate how many followers once has?
You know dove candy chocolate would still be able to see if the rock has followers the analytics on the back end
I'll show you forever. This is more about front-facing, you know, so I loved influencer marketing
I think most humans don't know how to price themselves which means a high percentage of them are wildly overpriced
It also means a high percentage of them were wildly under priced
for the attention and cosines of giving a brand or business in return and I could add word-of-mouth and
Influence to word of mouth has been around forever
John Wayne got paid by cigarette companies to smoke a cigarette and
and and in five hundred years some robot will be paid to
About the oil the robot uses for their joints. This is never going away. It's in perpetuity
And now there's way more people that have way more influence. It's a much longer tail
This is not just for the celebrities and athletes of the world and we haven't even started influencer marketing
Flew from Indy at the combine to LA. There's deer actors Mike trebled
What's up everybody, my name is payment I'm one of the cofounders of mad happy a brand based here in LA
We talk about all things positivity optimism and mental health
I had a chance to kick it with Gary last week to chat a little bit about project
We're working on more details to come on that soon and also got Hamlin in that episode of our upcoming
Podcast to talk all things mental health and how we can deal with that in today's world
And what would your takeaway be to a kid? That is you know?
20 years old right now and in trying to like navigate in this world, right like just practical things that they can implement right away
The first thing that excites me that's been really interesting to watch is you're actually in control
So that's been very empowering. I think we are teaching so many people like you need to be medicated
You need to be diagnosed. You need my help
We're gonna handhold you like not listen. There are some people that are born with real illnesses. We're medication
These are chemicals
But I but one thing that I've been better
Like one thing I definitely want to say to a lot of kids right now is like hey
You're way more in control than you think
Hey on how you see the world?
Beyond how much you value other people's judgments see on how you want to navigate the next 85 years of your life
I don't give a shit in a good way. Maybe like I'm gonna start changing terminology. These are important moments
It doesn't it's okay that the first 20 years didn't go the way you wanted. You have a team or
Like like it's just it's optimistic and like so hey if you realize the government your parents
The way the dice rolled don't control you you control you like just even knowing that to be true people talk about oh
The the awareness around mental health has helped
How about the awareness of your actually more in control than you think?
I think one of the terrible things that's happening in America politically is we're tearing apart left
right, and we keep going further and further which leads to this really difficult place where you're choosing between
being accountable being a horrible person or
Being a great person but not being accountable at all. That's bad
I'd like to see us get a little bit more mixed here. And so, you know, hey like you're in control
you're in control and I and I mean that
You paint your narrative right you go over four in a baseball game you get to decide if you like
You get decide if you say I fuckin suck or huh?
There's clearly something I'm missing. Let me go adjust that like if it's so empowering to know that nobody else is in control
It makes it so happy
like and I'm I'm definitely I'm definitely
That's why I'm so worried about
Like the separation of what I just said because it's leading to a lot of people in their youth thinking
somebody has some magical control over them like
to me the punchline of that is if you think
America has too much control over you good news. Don't cry a
Vote be moved to Sweden
But it's an interesting sentence
Because what we're doing is we're keyboard worrying and crying at Starbucks with our $6 coffee
When we could you know many kids are not gonna vote
You know many kids are not gonna move to Canada that they love so much
It's kind of like, you know
however
You want to say you want to say it wrong old school like shut the fuck up and do something about it
You want to say new school, which is like hey you're empowered
I don't give a shit how you want to say
it life is fucking amazing when you fucking grab it and I really think a lot of kids right now can grab it in a
way they can't this internet thing is
crazy
Like you should be the most optimistic generation of all time
You have the Internet like when I was a kid, they cared about what college you went to
When I was a kid at 15, I couldn't start a billion-dollar business
like I would have if I had the Internet at 15 or at least $1,000,000 eBay business, you know, and so
So much power so much control more than ever before ever before ever before. You're a rapper SoundCloud YouTube. Show me
Right, you're an athlete put up your own film on huddle and Instagram and get signed by you
Like you're in fucking control
Your next tommy hilfiger make it sell it. Show me
It's an amazing time to be alive the greatest time to be alive
That's what I see and not because it's easy for you now, Gary
That's what I always saw when it didn't look obvious for me either
I like that name
So this is the most carries in one spot that I'm sitting a minute three carries in one spot, I'm like shook
Just testing him going he's on it. He's not I like this guy over here. I
Know exactly, that's really cool
Love it. That's the closest tick tock shit every day. Have a great day. You too
Thank you, too
Busy I
Gotta I gotta make a family call. Danny don't have to close out this show. Okay. I love you
I'm being dead serious plug away from for minutes. I love you, Damon
It's the first time letting somebody close out the show. You got five minutes go
blog comment below what your thoughts are on the Astros cheating scandal and
Comment below on the fake news being spread about the Astros. Thank you. What?
I'm thinking it's the other person spot
It's a little basketball action like playing Michael Boyd's about a shoot from range
We have a triple content capture here. Give us a shot Mike. Oh
Just just off back iron, we're gonna reload and shoot again
All right money money in the bank
You didn't even go to college. Oh
I'm sorry to whoever's listening. I'm so sorry. I apologize
That feels so bad. I'm not mean I'm not mean whoever whatever you want to do
I encourage you jaison's make me be me now heading to the office
living that
California sunshine
Friday afternoon
Blogger the cash came mine tripping on a pet flame even if they were